my cousin nadia is taking a summer
calculus course and she called me last
night and she had some limit problems
and they were excellent problems so i
thought it was worthwhile to to make
videos on on the problems that she had
to figure out anyway so let's let's do
them if i remember them correctly i'm
doing this on memory so i hope the
answers work out like they did last
night when we were going over them on
the phone
so if i remember correctly the first
problem was the limit
as
z
approaches two
of
x oh no not y there's no x it's a z
of
of z
squared
plus
two
z
minus eight
all of that over
z
to the fourth
minus sixteen
so the first thing when you want to do
when you try a limit problem is well you
just you just try to substitute uh the
the value into you know maybe there's no
problem when z equals two and you just
evaluate the function at z equals two if
it's a continuous function then the
limit as it approaches two is going to
be the function at 2
but you immediately see a problem if you
put 2 right here 2 to the fourth minus
16 you get a 0 in the denominator which
is undefined so we have to figure out
some way to to get around that and 9
times out of 10 when you see a problem
like this the solution
because both the numerator and
denominator look factorable is to factor
the numerator and denominator so this is
equal to
the limit
as z approaches 2.
what's the numerator factored let's see
something
when you add two numbers you get
positive two and you multiply them you
get minus eight so it's probably plus
four and minus two
right so this is going to be
x plus no not an x i'm so conditioned
i'm like a dog
and
oh i can't even undo it anymore anyway
well
z
actually erase that i don't want to be
messy
let me erase i tried to undo it and
it doesn't remember everything
so it's z
let's say plus 4 times z minus 2 that's
just factoring a quadratic
and what is this this is this has the
form a squared minus b squared right so
that's
going to be
but a squared and if if this is a
squared minus b squared
a
a would be z squared right so it's z
squared plus four
times
z squared minus four
and then of course this also has the
form a squared plus b squared right
so this will further factor
into
z
plus 2
times z minus 2.
well our factoring paid off we see a
term in the numerator and the
denominator that are the same and not
only are they the same but that this is
the term that was giving us the problems
right because you put a 2 in here you
got a 0. so let's assume that we're not
evaluating it at z equals two
and so for all other values we can
divide those because those are going to
be the same values and then what are we
left with
this is equal to the limit and i've
changed colors arbitrarily as z
approaches 2 of
z
plus 4
over
z squared plus 4
times z plus 2
which is equal what that's equal to 6
over what's 2 squared plus 4
is
8
and then 2 plus 2
is 4
6 over 12 is equal to
one half there you go
i thought that was a a pretty
interesting problem let's do another one
and this one i i found even more
interesting that she gave me
it's really testing my memory to see if
i can but i remember the gist of the
problem so i might not get the exact
number she'd given me but
hopefully i get the exact properties
so it's the limit
as x
approaches
infinity
of
the square root and this see the square
root of
x
squared
plus four x
plus one
minus x
so when you look at this you're like
well let's see what's happening here
let's see this as you go to infinity
this term will get really big but then
we're taking the square root of it
and it seems like this term would
overpower this term
and then you know so maybe this kind of
converges to x but then we would
subtract an x so maybe it approaches
zero
so that's
at least that was my first intuition
when i spoke to her but as we will see
the intuition here is wrong
and really to do this you have to know a
little bit of a trick
and this trick pays off a lot whenever
you see
something with the square root sign and
subtracting something else if you want
to get rid of that square root sign so
we are going to do
is going to multiply
essentially the conjugate we normally
apply to complex numbers but you know if
we have something like a plus b
the conjugate is a minus b right or if
we have something like a minus b the
conjugate is a plus b and the reason why
and what we're going to do is we're
going to multiply by the conjugate of
this and why does why is that normal why
is that useful because we have a minus b
if we multiply it times a plus b we get
a squared minus b squared which will
make this radical sign disappear without
too much work so let's do that let's
multiply by the conjugate of this thing
but we can't just multiply it right we
have to multiply it by it over itself
because you can only to not change the
value of something you can only multiply
by one so let's multiply it by the
conjugate
x squared plus four x plus
one
plus x right that's the kind of right
instead of minus x we have a plus x and
we can't just multiply that we have to
multiply by one otherwise we'd be
changing the values so it's going to be
divided by the same thing
x squared plus four x plus one
plus x
let me erase this stuff down here so we
don't get distracted
don't want to get distracted and so what
do we have
this will become
the limit
as x
approaches infinity
well this is a minus b times a plus b so
we end up with a squared well what's
this squared
that's
x squared
plus four x
plus one
minus b squared well what's what's b
squared b is x so it's going to be minus
x squared and this is just algebra
divided by
this thing
the square root
of x squared plus 4
x
plus 1
plus x
so let's see there's a little
simplification we can do we can subtract
we can these two top two terms cancel
out
so x squared
minus x squared
and now let's see what we can do
well
since we're taking x to infinity and
this is what you normally do when you
take x to infinity we can divide
the numerator and denominator by our
highest our highest degree term and in
this case our highest degree term is x
right we have an x here and a next year
and then
and then when you take and then of
course when you divide something like
this by x you take infinity this will
approach zero so let's do that let's
divide the numerator and denominator by
x and remember anything you do the
numerator you have to do the denominator
otherwise you're changing the value
so times
1 over x
over 1 over x i'm just dividing the
numerator and denominator by x
so this is equal to
the limit
as x approaches infinity uh what's
that's going to be 4
plus 1 over x
over
let me ask a question what is 1 over x
times this thing what is
this is a bit of an algebra review but
1 over x what's 1 over x times you know
x squared plus 4x plus 1. i'm just doing
a little side here
well if we take the 1 over x and we put
it into the radical sign it becomes 1
over x squared
right this is the same thing as
you could say 1 squared over x squared
but you know
1 over x squared
you could say 1 squared you could put a
squared there but
times
x squared plus 4x plus 1.
and that should make sense to you right
because if we started with this we could
easily just take the square root of this
and take it outside and the square root
of this is 1 over x i'm just going in
the other direction right
so
assuming you're comfortable with that
everything under the radical sign even
though we're actually dividing by 1 over
x since we're going
into the radical sign we're actually
dividing by
x squared so it becomes
it becomes
this is the radical sign x squared
divided by x squared
is 1.
right i hope you understand why we're
dividing by x squared here we're
actually dividing by 1 over x when you
put another radical sign it becomes 1
over x squared let me put it this way
1 over x
times the square root of a
that's the same thing that equals
the square root of 1 squared over x
squared
times a right and this is just 1 over x
squared so that's the property or the
algebra that we're using so anyway we
divide all of this by x squared so
that becomes a 1
plus
4
over
x right
plus 1 over x squared
and then of course we divide this one by
this term right here we divide by
x right because it's not in the radical
sign
so that just becomes a one
so now what's the limit as x approaches
infinity
well as x approaches infinity this term
right here goes to zero
right one over infinity is zero this
term right here goes to zero
this term right here goes to zero and so
what are we left with
this is equal to
four
over
see the square root of one
plus one well that's just one so that
equals four
over two
which is equal to two
there you go
now let's do let's do one more one more
problem this is the third one she'd
given me in it we had to kind of brush
off our trig identities and really these
harder limit problems they're all about
kind of knowing your algebra and your
trigonometry really well just so you
know how to manipulate these functions
because the limit part you just have to
get into a form where taking the limit
is fairly straightforward so let's do
that trig problem
clear image
colors
so it was the limit
as x approaches 0
of cotangent
cotangent of 2x
was that it
yeah it was cotangent of 2x
over
the cosecant
of x
and this one just like previous problems
more than knowing your precalculus or
your calculus you need to know your trig
identities
so cosecant
cosecant
of x that's just one over sine i
remember that by saying it's not
intuitive you would have thought
cosecant is 1 over cosine but it's not
it's 1 over sine so i remember that it's
not intuitive and cotangent of
2x
cotangent of 2x is equal to 1 over
tangent of two x
and tangent to sine over cosine so
cosine's the cotangent is the opposite
so that equals cosine
of two x over sine of two x
right
okay
so what is this equal to so this is
going to be the limit
as x approaches 0. cotangent of 2x we
said was
cosine
of 2x
over sine of 2x
and then it's going to be all of that
over the cosecant of x well that's just
1 over sine of x 1 over sine of x
well if you divide by 1 over sine of x
that's the same thing as multiplying by
sine of x
so we have what do we have we have
we have cosine well we have sine of
sine of
x
times cosine of 2x
all of that divided by sine of 2x just
doing a little arithmetic
and we have a problem here still because
when you take x approaches 0 this term
right here goes to 0 and we have a zero
in the denominator which is just not
acceptable because it's undefined and
that's the whole reason why we're doing
this limit to begin with and actually
that's the first thing you should have
done you should have tried to put it and
you would have seen that you would have
gotten a
zero value in a denominator and it would
have been unevaluable
right because really this is just we
haven't even done any manipulation yet
this is the same thing as as this and if
you put the zero right here you get
undefined
so what can we do well this is where you
break out the trig or you brush off your
memories what is the sign of 2x equal
and this is your double one of the
double angle formulas
sine of two x
it is equal to two sine of x
cosine of x
so if you know that then then you've
gone a long way because
then it becomes pretty simple to
simplify so it becomes
2
sine of x
cosine of x
and then if we assume that x isn't zero
it's just approaching zero we can
divide the numerator and the denominator
by sine of x
and what are we left with we're left
with the limit
as x approaches zero of cosine
of 2x
over 2 cosine
of x
well what's cosine of
0
cosine of 0 is 1 right so cosine of 2
times 0 which is 0 that's also 1. so
that is equal to
one over right cosine of zero is one
over two times one
so it equals one half
there you go i think those are
three fairly meaty limit problems and if
you know that you're probably prepared
for something that your your calculus
teacher might throw at you see you in a
future video